هذه هي الكره التي ركبها اللاعبون خلال
مراحل المجموعات في اول نسخه لكاس العالم
التي اقيمت في الاوروغواي في عام 1930 كره
مر عليها اكثر من 90 عاما وقتها كانت هذه
الكره تمتص المياه يثقل وزنها واحيانا
تصيب اللاعبين في اقدامهم ومن يكن سيء
الحظ قد تركل وجهه ليدخل في الم لا يشعر
به الا من تجره وهي الان موجوده في معرض
كاس العالم
[موسيقى]
فيفا
[تصفيق]
حتى وصلنا للمباراه النهائيه المباراه
التي كانت ترفاها منتخبي الارجنتين
والاوروجواي حضور الجماهيري كبير
اثناء المباراه
الكرات المصنوعه من جلود الحيوانات وقتها
كانت مفارا جدلا بسبب وزنها وسمك ونوعيه
جلدها وجودتها منتخب الارجنتين جاء
البطوله ومعه كراته الخاصه ورفض ان يخوض
المباراه النهائيه بهذه الكره فقد كانت من
صناعه ارجوانيه قالوا انها كره لم يعتادوا
عليها وان لاعب الخصم يعرفونها جيدا نريد
ان نلعب بكره ارجنتينيه الصنع منتخب
الاوروغواي رفض هذا الطلبه تماما وهنا وقع
الخلاف
[موسيقى]
تتدخل هذا الانيق البلجيكي جون لانجاز
فاقترح ان يتم لعب الشوط الاول بكره القدم
الارجنتيني والشوط الثاني بكره القدم
الارجوانيه وافق الفريقان وبدات المباراه
ولان لاعب الارجنتين يعرفون نقاط قوه وضعف
كرهتهم تقدموا في الشوط الاول بهدفين
مقابل هدف واحد كاد منتخب التانجو يخطف
اللقب بدا شوط المباراه الثاني اي انه حان
وقت المنتخب الاوروغواي ان يستخدم كرهته
الخاصه وما انذاعه اقدامه لاعبي منتخب
الاوروغواي كرهتهم امام خصم عنيد حتى تم
احرازه اربعه اهداف في شباك الثاني
[تصفيق]
وكلمه السر كانت في كره اوروغوانيه لينتهي
اللقاء بنتيجه اربعه مقابل اثنين
ويسدل الستار على مباراه لعبت بكره
ارجنتينيه في شوطها الاول وكره ارجوانيه
في شوطها الثاني وخلال السنوات اللاحقه
وتحديدا في عام 1960 تم انتاج اول كره
صناعيه كليا بواسطه الجلد الصناعي مع
امتصاص اقل بكثير للمياه وراحه اكثر
للاقدام وسرعه ارتداد الاعلى
[موسيقى]